I had maybe been a couple of psychics in
my life not and I but it was like I or
it was already paid for
and I decided to go okay I said I did go
I said Karen you want to come with me
sure
so it's this amazing woman named Dolores
Catalucci
Italian broad a woman who finds missing
children and works for the police
station she's an amazing psychic and she
says she's in Van Nuys like in on
Calvert Street
you stay in your car until I call you
when I call you get out of the car
well obviously because I saw Brad Pitt
and Jennifer Aniston walking out of this
house like major people like it so you
walk in the first thing she does she
goes give me give me a kiss give me
jewelry give me your phone give me
something I she disappears for less than
30 seconds later she comes back she goes
put your tape recorder on get your pick
start writing and she starts spewing out
a whole bunch of information
and she says
you've had a rough go at this you're
you're gonna be okay
it's your health is gonna figure itself
out you're gonna be okay not without
struggle and she started talking to me
about my dad and that my dad was going
to develop dementia and he did and
Alzheimer's she told me that my sisters
can be in full remission from breast
cancer that happened
and then she told me you're going to be
doing a TV show and I'm going fantastic
and I'm thinking okay it's this MTV show
that I pitched right she goes no no
that's not that one and she goes look
she goes it's a talent show I go like
Star Search goes I don't know but it's
it's gonna be the biggest thing of your
career you think music's big really she
said all this not only did she say all
of this she went as far as telling me
that I'm going to be sitting next
to it a hole from across the pond
and eight and then African-American guy
that you somehow know
I'm like I'm not even paying attention
because I'm not like I'm not doing a
time that's crazy not doing a talent
show
and she goes honey willed it to happen I
I can I read from
three years from now to three years and
I you willed it to happen how long after
you saw her did you get this call almost
three years later
so
remember oh she asked me do you want do
you want her to be in your reading I
said I don't care yeah fine so Tara was
in the reading with me
I forget about all of this I'm paying
attention to my sister self and my dad's
Health
um
to watch your dad because he's gonna
start losing his motor skills and he's
gonna fall and break his ankle or
something and he did it was just it was
sad things were happening I didn't I
never paid attention to what she said I
had a tape recording of it I had notes
from it
and um two and a half years later
weirdest thing I get a phone call from
my attorney and business manager saying
and my publisher
because what I didn't tell you is when I
missed my flight and I had to stay over
another hotel
Cara
worked on this a song for my post
divorce the the Vintage you know retro
disco song that I was doing about Emilio
rest of us no no the the second one that
I don't get to I don't even have to talk
about because it was not it was enough
it was another one it was an old but we
we finished the song and that was how
I'm and then two two and a half three
weeks ago she was living with me and she
was in that reading with me and I I
introduced her to
different writing camps of people that I
know
um she was a funny roommate uh and the
reason I'm telling you all this because
you know my stories are crazy as they
are
two and a half years later I get a call
I'm in a hot I'm I'm in the hospital
bed and my publisher first says this
not my attorney my publisher says are
you sitting down little did he know I
was two days out of yet now my
11th or 12th surgery 13th surgery now it
was like towards tail end of
it I go yeah he goes that song that you
worked on with Kara
um
I pitched it to an artist that was huge
before you ever came out Paula but
Australian girl Locomotion Kylie mcnug
he goes yes she's on a very small label
called London Beat Records and loves the
song and she removed
scratchly vocals she put her lead vocal
on
and he goes Paula it looks like it's
going to enter the charts number one in
the UK
blessing
Kara's first number one record it was
with you
for another artist that was given to
Kylie Minogue
it went number one in every territory
except it wasn't released in one
territory the United States a song
called spinning around
now that's the first number one for her
for Cara and it's a a Renaissance for
Kylie Minogue because now her world
explodes to have the coming from when I
hear Underdog Story I'm like give it
give it I'm all about the underdog
now because of that
several months later I get a call from
my attorney and business Magic One
Paul you need to sign off on licensing
and Mechanicals for the song that you
did with Kara and this guy IRA and it's
um
it it's there's it's for a show in the
UK
some kind of talent show nothing's going
off in my brain no Dolores Catalucci and
there was another psychic named Miss
Faye out here who I saw that predicted
the same exact thing all within a
relatively one year Time same thing same
people all right keep going with this so
now I'm going ugh I go can I get the
number of the producer you're talking to
and my attorney my publisher everyone
who's worked with me my agents they know
I'm tenacious
I'm looking for a way to
help
these artists I hear it's a talent show
and guess what
every kid in this new UK show called pop
Idol is coming in and auditioning
singing acapella spinning around
the song that was went number one that
from Cara myself and this guy IRA
now
I call this woman I keep getting hung up
on because they don't believe it's me
that kind of stuff and it's like oh my
God and I keep calling and finally I
just started humming straight up
and I could hear the phone
because it's her it's her and this woman
Claire Howell got on the phone who's the
producer and she went and on I said I
would love to somehow get involved and
help
keep I'm a choreographer and I work with
artists I work with Michael for Jackson
for six years George Michael I give
signature let me work with I'm thinking
anything and everything I can to get
away from I'm in the hospital right now
on my 12th surgery 13th surgery
she goes oh my God that would be
fantastic she goes listen we're at
school she was English why what what
accent am I doing now
oh did I go into it oh go ahead go ahead
I'm back to the American because I'd
like to save the British first Simon
um
actually went on to say that you know we
just begun it's the biggest show in the
UK
the queen clears her diary to vote
I went what oh yes the country boats I
went huh she goes and it's brutal you
know everyone talks behind you back in
in America but here
there are these two wretched guys
one is a big producer named Pete
Waterman I go I know Pete Bananarama Ace
of Base and this other guy who's an a r
executive named Simon Cowell they're
horrible they make young men fall to
their knees crying in embarrassment
because they they tell you that you suck
I went oh my God and there's a really
sweet girl in the middle
who's a radio DJ
and it's hosted by these two comedians